I'm Steven crowded with PJTV here at the
Denton County Health Care townhall in
Texas I'm here to investigate the the
angry mob scene we've heard the horror
stories and by God I just want to come
at you with the hard-hitting journalism
so I've decided to go in there myself
you can thank me later so ma'am what
exactly are you doing here at this
healthcare townhall I'm here to show up
as an American citizen I am NOT in
support of the health care bill but I
believe that it it falls into a much
bigger issue and it said that ma'am here
just just just take this just leave me
alone please oh no I don't want any
trouble I don't want any - I don't want
any trouble
what are you doing here at the
healthcare protest pastel purple clearly
some kind of gang color I'm totally
against the bill that they have out
right now HR 3200 hey Nancy calm down
you're in a safe place with people who
care about you well I think this is a
meeting of everyday Americans you know
wanting to know what's going on so you
think that as an American citizen you
have the right to know that's right I
have a right to know anything that I
want to know this is a free country
there he had straight from the crazies
mouths Troy how old are you I'm thirteen
thirteen and what exactly are you doing
at the healthcare protest well I'm a
degree a PhD in what sir in instigating
mob violence
clearly you're shill your corporate
mouthpiece because she's dressed in
nothing but nice clothing why are you
here well I just had some concerns
because I'm not sure really
they're not even reading this bill and I
don't calm down okay okay my parents tax
dollars and everything is going to acorn
and Obamacare and I'm angry that the
government is spending money so that
I'll have to pay for when I grow up okay
so you're 13 so you know acorn is not
the thing that you see falling from
trees I'm just not sure that they're
really
very honest with us about some of the
details and you're gonna have to lower
your voice and stop being so angry if
we're gonna do this interview I'm trying
to be civil here okay they spend and
spin-spin what you have admitted that
you are in fact angry yes I am angry
they're not gonna tell us what the
possible ramifications over alright so
we are here with the angry mob we're
gonna see if we can get a little bit
closer later on we're gonna inch our way
forward
as you can see the swastika equivalent
that Nancy Pelosi was talking about
they've even brought beverages to keep
these terrible gangbangers hydrated
there's a human hand in here these
people are clearly hostile I think they
have guns and I'm from I see
okay but jammer man just been swallowed
by the mob I've gotta make it out of
here
fill this you can I need help